what do you want to rap about
what did you just whisper to someone and
say you have one right
yeah wait do you guys go on
purposely
purposely
i think it's the important word here
i mean i would also say that the words
ejaculating and grandmother are also
important but
purposely ejaculating on your
grandmother
okay
cool
and you knew he had that prepared
is that how you discussing this in the
line like just in case a white british
man is like what would you like a rap
about
you got one right yeah purposely
ejaculating on your grandmother
cool have you set a hand up yeah
the craziest thing a new york city rat
has seen
yeah
okay cool
back of the room um what would you like
a rap about
canadians
comedians
canadians okay cool
i was like it is pretty meta someone
else was like comedian so i was like
canadian comedians norm mcdonald and
i could be i know a bunch of canadian
comedians because i got there but you
won't know how they were
canadian chameleon what are you doing
this isn't a tongue twister
you fancy yourself a rapper as well you
like canadian comedians canadian
comedian
canadian chameleon obedience
i hate you all i hear you all um
okay
so canadian comedian comedians
craziest thing new york has seen and
what this man said um and then okay
those people people who are kind of over
here what you guys want to wrap up
andrew prince andrew okay yeah yeah
yeah we all know him don't we me
personally but um
i'm gonna could you pass that back to
the oh wait wait do it up here
okay cool is that we can do it from over
there but we were like don't give your
phone to that guy he looks sketchy
she wearing a cap in england and if you
wear cats in england if you wear a cap
that means that you're you're a violent
past um
i'll leave that here because i bring my
own
and this one feels like it's been bought
off amazon and not from an authentic
apple shop this this is too stiff
that's the apple one is much floppier
as demonstrated
if i put down we get some [ __ ]
spyware on my phone
let's step your game up comedy seller
first party peripherals please
um they're called peripherals
the little things that you buy
what do you call them over here then
accessories no accessories can be
anything peripheral dongles
yeah i like that word but a technical
word term is peripheral
so so far
here's one um canadian comedian
chameleons
prince andrew and the crazy thing i knew
at rat scene one final suggestion this
can come from anywhere just the the one
rule stipulation is the stipulation is
wave to stipulation uh it has to be the
best one so far so what did you say
vagina slurping well done you passed the
test that's
the best one so far
vagina did someone say what is it yeah
i'll explain in the wrap
i don't know if that's a spit that might
be a tick-tock trend i'm not aware of
vagina slurping
what
the queen of england's vagina slurping
uh yo your accent is eastern european
where are you from
you're from chicago oh no
you're just drunk okay that was pretty
cute
it was so sweet
the queen of england's vagina slurping
i'm just british i am
thank you so the queen of england's
vagina's schlurping
canadian comedian chameleons crazy on
your right has ever seen prince andrew
and purposely ejaculating on your
grandmother um
this beat i'm going to give it you i
think full volume uh i've not used this
beat before so this is a fun time so
turn it up a little bit for me yeah
there's no show on next door is it so we
don't have to worry about disturbing
them but this is a little rap about all
that stuff and i'm i'm very excited yeah
cool
[Applause]
chicago waxing from the drunk lady i
don't understand you let me serve her up
my name's prince andrew hello i made a
settlement out of court a lady virginia
zhufra did report that when she was 17 i
meddled in her
admittedly i had sarah ferguson i was
married to her but how weird could i get
it didn't really happen why because i
can't sweat i was in the falklands in
the war they started strafing their
ammunition and i saw the enemy i ran
away his sweat glands dried up you're
looking at me you've got your eyes up
like yeah i'm not sure i like this bit
of the show he thinks i'm eating
european but i'm from chicago i'd like
to share my words yeah i'll make it
easier i'm from chicago like deep dish
pizza that's okay we did the andrew
prince slur in my words maybe i would
take a chance to try and think about
this with the ccc with the canadian
chameleons that do the comedy cc like a
spanish agreement ccc like 50
more on an email carbon copy cc clever
little pun coming easy up i'm over there
everyone's appalled canadian comedy i'm
blending into the brick wall no one can
see me getting famous so large chameleon
up here cause they're camouflaged if you
didn't make sense if you didn't do that
here we go let me talk about on my back
i see the lady so wrinkly the bed she's
smooth not wrinkly i'm going down i'm a
dude called prince philip i'm gonna fill
it with my mouth i'm over here
buckingham palace that is my house i'm
like
i'll make you feel dizzy i'll lick your
vagina till i get you in a tizzy
admittedly this is in 2020 because now
prince philip is dead yeah he might be
in the ground don't come on me and rise
from the depths like a prince philip
zombie still he's there he's earning all
of his prince philip titles by slurping
he's like oh lizzy we used to really own
china here we go i'm going to put my
tongue in your vagina it's so nice yes
it makes sense when i'm looking there
trying to lick the clitoris and let me
say this to you doesn't call it a
clitoris she calls it her crown jewel
hey that's a fun pun is obscene why
would i say this the craziest thing i've
ever seen wasn't that i'm a new york
sewer maybe in the subway yeah i'm
pursuing that my whole life i'm on the
8th brain or the q or the n and the
shit's insane i'll tell you what it was
i'm really glad you weighed i saw a guy
purposely ejaculate on his grandmother
you can't do that even i pursue bits of
pizza i'm dragging them up the stairs
but he purposely did it like she was
aware she was like oh really my grandson
you want to make sure i'm stopped and
frozen to place oh you'll really start
to rob it sounds like the title of the
thing on pornhub really deliberate
wanking is shaft granny is this okay
well you asked ah yeah i'm gonna cover
you with jizz and afterwards say grandma
can you knit me some new clothes maybe
out of wool there you go you gave granny
an earful of sperm in a face when you're
coming with your dick but admittedly the
queen elizabeth slurping bit with sick
[Applause]